celebri bari siamo stati su close your
eyes che va sempre figo dire il nome in
inglese il problema è che non so per la
mente se però il titolo posso dire c'è
sempre quel tipo inquietante nello
sfondo eravamo rimasti che dove diavoli
rossi non me lo ricordo molto io eccolo
eccolo qua ok mi ha fatto ripartire
tutto questa cosa non me la ricordavo
possiamo andare avanti si è scoperto che
se chiudi gli occhi e chiude anche la
porta prima che qualcosa ci in gruppi
lano kg a porta per la scritta behind
indietro e poi c'è questo simbolo un po
strano che non ho ben capito cos'è però
è che questo un simbolo di qua dietro ma
va a cagare e non avevo capire sono
ragazzi ci mette un po ad arrivare alle
cose non potete pretendere non sono
ingegneri sono noi youtuber ok a di
siamo arrivati lì siamo andati prima
quella del behind quindi questa è la
porta che sia aperta vai che bello
mi piace andare avanti salve a posso
passare di sotto allora comunque in sto
gioco per chi non se lo ricordasse se
chiudi gli occhi vedi cose in teoria
esci da questo porco non l'ho capito un
attimo ma perché quasi chiusa la porta a
caso quest'anno sbarra chiusa prima non
c'era chi è che il monache che strozza i
robot urlando cos'è
se guardate troppo i video di mettervi
se succede questo non lo fa
maronna che cazzate che fa tu porca eva
cos'era chi era ciao sentiti gli occhi
sta fermi torniamo dopo salemi che devo
vedere che cosa stanno facendo non fosse
non è vero aia che grotto online su rai
storia dichiara noi che non è comparsa
una faccia i tuoi occhi sono stati
rubati e quindi lo vogliono rubarmi gli
occhi e per questo che sto con gli occhi
chiusi non mi trovano non lo sapevo qui
ai quasi non li vedo perché
non li vedo perchè non vedo una mazza
così alla pace un coso porca di una
bacca lurida morta ieri perché è pronta
gioco perché ha deciso di giocare sta
roba
madonna che brutto la porta cos'è sta
roba qua una forza apri apri tutti pure
la chat e sarà lino vista mamma mia e
modo torna tutti dietro ricordandomi si
è figura
ok perfetto e stato orribile
vai più che è stato bruttissimo noi
input cena lo vedo a prova sia per tra
parte perché che bello nato
[Musica]
grazie alla madonna
ma c'è addirittura una una mano che
spunta da un'altra mano va bene cosa
tocchi cosa tocchi ti denuncio tutta la
vita però vabbè ma posso entrare che
bello sempre desiderato freddo che
questo succede ai cambiato il mondo
proprio qualcuno una spiegazione a tutto
questo ci qualcuno ce l'ha perché non ho
mica capito cosa dire di quattro fetta
addirittura qua c'è una l'ascensore
invisibile va bene un capitolo gut è
tantissima e voi che avete fatto questo
gioco ve lo dico o un milione di porte è
una sempre della minkia spettacolo ecco
madonna blu lsd piena qua alle 4 del
mattino a milano in discoteca uguale
xavi giuro ci hanno fatti deformati così
che tutti potessero avere paura di noi
ha quindi pietro l'hanno fatto così
apposta avevano fai paura anzi se così
carino ti metterei sul comò fa più paura
e lampi lampioni con la colloquio se
doveste sincero provola sono altri
messaggi gli uomini nel cielo ci hanno
mentito
chi sono quei quelli sono invece non si
con le bugie
poi la madonna salve deve entrare anche
nella sua mascella
quelle sono due gambe aperte quella è
una vagina
non facciamo domande questa mi sembra
veramente una cosa bruttissima da vedere
però mentre entriamo oppure 16 ora e 45
minuti e 11 secondi ok o di origami
ricorda anti chambers a roma ha fatto un
cavalca che brutto
[Musica]
non si è fermato
vitamin dietro l'altro occhio mi rifiuto
di rimanere cieco cosa no non ho capito
questo è successo allora che non ho
capito quest'ultima parte meno male però
quando si toglie la musica è sempre un
momento un po di merda quindi madonna
può arrivare alla luce verde prima che
mi ingrossino voi siete scemi ma voi
siete interrogati nella ri come avesse
tempo fa pure i vasi
anche qui la vasta preso malissimo
perfetto ce l'ho fatta
il primo tentativo incredibile ma io ho
una mano robotica e non lo sapevo o si è
consumata fuori alle erbe l'istanza che
passo mi sembra di andare sempre quindi
l'incasinato che già è un casino sto
gioco
cosa mi chiama roba numerica figurato
contare quanti oggetti ci sono le stanze
a 12 34
il primo numero 4 il secondo 12 e basta
425 giusto fa chiedere ai lo vede il
solving problems ai cash and without the
scala a posto ma poi scusate la gamma è
il luogo dove sono cos'è cioè un si
capisce ma neanche per sbaglio dove
seguiamo le frecce facciamo prima un ca
la prefazione
ti prego
porca vacca che voluto sono incastrato
in un ostellino fai te
[Musica]
vabbè satana satana nell'ombra il
demonio nel dl di mordor rottami pur in
faccia arriviamo da qualche parte per
cortesia
ti prego un'ora che cammino ecco la
porta frey un ascensore era l'ascensore
sono dentro grazie a dio web è stato
orribile
dal vettore cinquegrana la cassa 4
salvatore cinquegrana casa 4 ma che non
sentivo niente perché il profeta
però non ho mai capito cosa devo fare
qua porca vacca che brutta cosa ho visto
consiglio c'è di magari no ma no se osi
libro slim pc
porca vacca solo nostro
aiuto 34 minuti sono diventato un mostro
era ridotto a morire tracia scritto mi
ami ha via via
vendo cose che non mi piacciono
conti raga conte ansiolitica st parte vi
prego
salve
[Musica]
siamo ritornati all'inizio del gioco ma
siete serie una presa per il kill
[Musica]
vabbè ma basta mi ha preso per il culo
23 22 sono secondi exit vado all'uscita
avevo la possibilità di scegliere
secondo me ho scelto esattamente la cosa
sbagliata però vabbè
scommettete che dovevo andare
esattamente dall'altra parte
oh che bel finale
che bel finale
grazie colin gunn bigami della spending
the us open the rye
ok quindi se allora privano gli eroi
loro occhi morivamo tutti quindi io
dovevo andare dall'altra parte tra due
vie
ho scelto quella sbagliata però spero
ragazzi che video vi sia piaciuto e
questa rappresenta i costi sono riuscito
come te mi piace anche socialmente dove
si siano resi schiavi non ci vediamo
corpo seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]